foreign
[Music]
has changed the game for a number of
industries that need to scale at a
moment's notice look no further than
e-commerce as a prime example
of course there are many moving Parts in
any e-commerce app payments inventory
recommendations customer carts and more
deploying each of these pieces as
individual microservices is one way
folks have improved the ability to move
and quickly scale to make this easier
we're announcing a jumpstart solution
for deploying an e-commerce website
using microservices running in a Google
kubernetes engine cluster all in a
matter of minutes
now in theory the microservices for an
e-commerce web app could be deployed to
just about any compute runtime in
practice however you're thinking about
more than just running this code you're
thinking about how to do so in a
reliable way where it can scale and
Survey Global customer base
this is where our jumpstart solution
comes in
now if this is your first time hearing
of a jumpstart solution they are
packaged Google Cloud resources that can
be quickly deployed directly from the
Google Cloud console
if you'd like to make changes to the
solution we've also built the foundation
of these Solutions in terraform which
you can pull locally and customize to
your liking and while they are not
intended for production use out of the
box they do contain patterns that can be
adopted as you prepare a set of
e-commerce microservices for production
in Google Cloud
in this solution we are simplifying the
deployment of a set of microservices
running across two Google kubernetes
engine clusters one in the US and one in
Europe all to demonstrate running a
global e-commerce website in this case
for a fictional company named symbol
shops
let's dive into the architecture
naturally a user will first access the
symbol shops Front End using a browser
which will send an HTTP request to a
Google Cloud load balancer with a single
anycast IP address
this is a global load balancer that
exists at Google's Edge points of
presence directing traffic to the
appropriate destination within Google
Cloud
this request is routed to one of two gke
clusters where the front end is running
and is configured via a kubernetes
resource called multi-cluster Ingress
by default this request is routed to the
clustered geographically closest to you
for lower latency the request is then
processed and handled by the rest of the
backend microservices in that cluster
that make up all the other functionality
you'd expect in an e-commerce app
that is with one exception the
application's card service stores the
state of the user's shopping cart while
they're visiting the site using a redis
database
this redis instance is deployed to the
US cluster only and back-end services
from the EU cluster access this using
another kubernetes resource called a
multi-cluster service
perhaps the most important aspect of
these clusters is that they are both gke
autopilot clusters for symbol shops this
means that when there are more visitors
to the site than usual the Clusters can
automatically scale up the amount of CPU
memory and storage they use based on the
application's needs that you specify
with autopilot enabled the platform
admin doesn't have to worry about
pre-provisioning and paying for more
Cloud resources before a scaling event
or risk not being able to handle the
scaling events due to lack of resources
upon deployment of each of these
jumpstart Solutions you'll be able to
access and load test the symbol Shop's
eCommerce web app running on Google
Cloud
so what now
as I mentioned each of these Solutions
are accessible in the Google Cloud
console if you navigate to products and
solutions and then jumpstart Solutions
you can navigate to e-commerce web app
on kubernetes just a few clicks and
you'll be up and running
you can also reference our solution
guides to dig deeper into the
architecture and learn about customizing
the solution
finally you can also explore our
interactive tutorials that walk you
through the various components of the
solution
check out the links below to try out
this jumpstart solution for yourself
[Music]